all right good good evening I guess to
our viewers watching in Europe good
afternoon here on the East Coast and
good afternoon I guess also on the west
coast good morning if you're in Hawaii I
guess we will we will we will leave it
there we are again on the precipice of
another white house coronavirus press
briefing expected scheduled for 5:00
p.m. you know who knows when it's really
going to start and I see people already
reacting to what is increasingly out of
control hair that I am dealing with and
I expect we will be dealing with it
for some time or some time we will
update of course the latest global and
US coronavirus numbers I'm going to talk
a little bit about Sweden I'm going to
talk about obesity I'm going to talk
about the tuberculosis vaccine now being
explored as something that might be
useful in the fight against kovat 19
we are monitoring three different
streams to see if at any point we have a
view of what's happening in the press
briefing room I've just read that now
starting today the reporters in the
press briefing room are being tested for
kovat 19 and they are expected I mean
what's the point if they can't have the
results but they're expected to get
their results before the start of the
press briefing before they're allowed
into the room so we will we will
continue to explore that let me say oh
I'm gonna read a few Super chats because
they're already coming in which I very
much appreciate and then I'm gonna get
to some of the different data data and
all of that stuff Andrew Dwyer says we
need you to teach your friend Kyle how
to livestream with super chats he was
writing the struggle bus this morning
although his analysis was on point oh I
don't know what he was struggling just a
streamer
I don't know thanks to Frank drugs Emma
and David Ross man for signing up on
YouTube Marie Tellez sends a super chat
Krieg st. sends a super chat Zach
Williams says I'm a staunch Bernie
supporter vote
for Biden I can't have Trump picking
RBG's replacement who in their right
mind would vote for him yeah I have a
20-minute video which we just published
to my youtube channel called Bernie out
and analysis and you know the thing is
every time I do a 20 minute video on one
topic it gets very few views but the
people who watch it seem to appreciate
it more so in any case consider checking
out that I'm not gonna do any Bernie
Biden stuff on this stream because we
just published a 20 minute video about
it to YouTube
and I will be directing all enquiries on
that subject directly to the YouTube
channel thanks to a Koyo madrid for the
super chat oh did we are we getting some
that anything happened no we're still
not live in the room thanks to Ashley
Pearson who says hi from Louisiana keep
doing a great job thanks Ashley
incredible said here's my support hope
the David Pakman show is doing well a
jammu oma wale says watched Susan Rice
on MSNBC explain how she prepped the
White House so sad the lies Trump tells
very much so Derrick Vandervoort
says Falwell got arrest warrants issued
for journalists who criticized him over
reopening Liberty University he is a
disgrace to the Shenandoah Valley yes he
is thanks again to Morita les Brooks
Madden says off-topic but how difficult
is it to run your own show how many
hours a week do you work how do you keep
yourself motivated the news keeps me
vote motivated every day is a new day
where I want to talk about what's going
on I work you know it's certainly full
tie it's a heavy full-time job
especially during coronavirus there's a
lot of 13 hour days between you know
prepping for the broadcast show doing
the broadcast show doing the business
supervising and working with our staff
doing the live stream prepping for the
next day's show that there's certainly
long day's our buckle says is we'll see
what happens included in bingo it's not
yet but it probably doing my hair also
extends the day a lot yeah it probably
should be we'll see what happens should
probably be included would be my guess
okay let's get to the latest numbers
globally we are now just shy of 1.6
million known cases and we are rapidly
approaching six-figure death toll the
United States still very much number one
and expected to remain that way more
than three times the number of cases of
any other country despite the fact that
we aren't testing that much remember if
we sort by tests per capita which is a
term that eludes Donald Trump we are
currently in tests per capita 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20
21 22 23 24 25 26 27 28 29 30 31 32 33
34 35 36 37 38 39 40 41 42 43
we are currently 43rd globally in tests
per capita so for sure this number is
very very low the only upside to that
number being low is that our death rate
is actually lower than what the official
numbers suggest let's now look at the
official United States numbers in more
detail four hundred and sixty-two
thousand cases 16,000 deaths still New
York and New Jersey playing a very very
big role in the cases but Michigan
California and Massachusetts are now
climbing very important you also have to
look at tests per population here when
you look for example at my state
Massachusetts compared to Pennsylvania
both have about 18,000 cases in
Massachusetts we've tested 14,000 people
for every million whereas Pennsylvania
has only tested 8,000 people this
testing disparity is a really big deal
and we need to continue to keep an eye
on that as we think about where
different states are in their curves so
to speak let's now go and look at the
big picture numbers it's
starting to look like we are leveling
off on new cases but of course you have
to account for how much are we testing
when we think about that active cases of
course continue to climb
eventually more people will recover each
day than get infected and the number of
active cases will start to decline when
we look at deaths we had two very very
bad days
very bad days as of right now let me
find the us here briefly as of right now
we are already at 1650 for the day we've
still got you know many hours left here
and we will see where that comes out at
a certain point this is going to going
to turn around we just don't know when
lastly the IH ME model has not been
updated today as you can see here it was
last updated on April 8 currently we are
three days from the peak according to
this model that will be on April 12 the
peak of course will really be a plateau
where we will be over 2,000 deaths a day
for something like 10 days we will be
over 1500 deaths a day for what is
expected to be you know more like three
weeks almost so it's it's going to get
very very ugly and the total death
projections for a wave one we'll talk
about waves momentarily 60,000 deaths
almost all of those coming by May 25th
ish May 21st
ish somewhere somewhere in that range
welcome if you were joint just joining
us we are standing by for the White
House press briefing no update yet from
Donald Trump on exactly when it will be
taking place scheduled for now often
delayed by 30 to 45 minutes if anybody
is aware of a stream that is in the room
so we can see what's going on let me
know sometimes when i refresh youtube
will suggest other streams I'm not
seeing any but let me know let me know
if anybody knows of a stream and this is
the c-span feed they are not yet live
Washington Post is not live and the
White House stream is not live so let me
know okay
Oh somebody recommending a stream here
doesn't look like it okay no we don't
have anything anything yet
very good okay other super chats coming
in Daniel Rivera says what leftist
policies do you think Biden would be
open to I will talk I'm gonna have a
video about that on Monday video about
that on Monday and as I said I am NOT
gonna do any Burnie Biden Trump stuff
today because we just published a 20
minute video about it and I don't want
to fill up the stream with it FoxNews
coronavirus live someone says Fox News
is live in the room let's take a look
okay I'd rather get away from Fox News
once the stream starts but ah there we
go very good okay yeah once again they
are working on lighting and the room
very very empty so far oh and Fox is
announcing that they have actually
pushed back to 6:00 p.m.
Wow okay all right well we've got some
time to do stuff and discuss things in
that case allison ly been good has
subscribed on YouTube Daniel Krieger
says is it relevant that the u.s. is
seventh in cases per capita it is
relevant but again when we're only forty
third in testing per capita our cases
per capita number is also going to be
very very skewed Matt bond says my head
hurts from trying to tell trumpets that
stock from Obama's years would probably
be out of date they don't get masks have
expiration dates yeah but I don't know
let's see n95 mask expiration date I
think it's very very long let's see here
people aside from professionals still
effective may offer protection
expiration dates effective use right
it's a question of the seal it appears
but even expired masks still provide
protection it appears yeah
I'm not taking a position on the concept
of the expiration I mean I don't deny
that there is an expiration date I'm
just not taking a position on the
effectiveness of an expired mask at this
point I just don't know enough about it
right now Darrin says hey David my own
country's Prime Minister got a pat on
the back from across all parties even
though he is what he is would Donald get
the same treatment do you think well
it's not a fair question unless we we we
have similar behavior we can't say Trump
is gonna get the same treatment in both
parties would say XY or Z
if Trump did a unanimously good job I
think he would get I think he would get
compliments from everybody he's done in
some ways he's done okay in some ways
he's done terribly Zachary Monroe says
David I don't like Biden and I hate
Trump
are there any third party candidates you
think have a chance if they get enough
of the votes no no it's it's Biden or
Trump the next president will be Biden
or Trump again unless one of the
candidates dies or falls into a coma its
Biden or Trump five to one says your
hair is da bomb here is two bucks Hawk
Sameach thank you
myth smithy says thanks for virtual
companionship new member from Montreal
thank you very much I appreciate that
okay let's look at a few other things
there is a new report that obesity is a
major coronavirus risk factor now
implicitly we suspected this especially
when you look at the comorbidities many
of them are highly associated with
obesity and there is now a statement
from the chief epidemiologist in France
who said yesterday that obesity is a
major major factor and that even when
you look at the mortality rate it is
skewed towards those who are obese and
every indication that this was the case
all along and if the u.s. ends up with a
disproportionately high birth rate I
would not not birth rate death rate from
the virus
it wouldn't be shocking that it may be
connected to the high obesity rate in
the United States and when you look at
other countries with a high obesity rate
Mexico for example
I don't off the top of my head I don't
remember what the other high obesity
rate countries are it would not be at
all surprising that there is a
connection there second thing I wanted
to talk about today there is now more
and more discussion of a second wave of
kovat 19:00 and for better or for worse
whatever we believe about the
trustworthiness of Chinese data on cases
and deaths doesn't really matter at this
point what is very clear is that we are
starting to learn including from Chinese
reports if nothing else that the second
wave is very likely to be a thing dr.
Anthony Fauci has been talking about
this a lot of different health experts
have been talking about it by every
indication when we say that the model
predicts 60,000 deaths by August this is
wave 1 and we believe that there will be
a second wave that may coincide with the
flu season which I think the flu season
at least in much of the north of the
United States starts in early October
ish I think he going into November which
is when people are going to be voting of
course that there is going to be a
second wave and then potentially a third
wave in 2021 by 20 by fall of 2026 seven
months from now we are unlikely to have
a vac we're not going to have a vaccine
I don't even know why I say unlikely
we're not going to have a vaccine unless
you know Anthony foutch II sort of tease
the idea maybe there could be if there
is an aviary high efficacy signal from a
vaccine maybe you could move it up a few
months but it still likely would be you
know 2021 not maybe just not late 2021
early 2021
we will hopefully by the end of the
second wave have some therapeutic
treatments antivirals other things that
could be tests we just don't know yet a
lot of these random randomized
controlled trials are happening now so
it is again going to be social
distancing and closing down that is
going to prevent prevent wave - how the
timing of that second wave will interact
with the presidential election here in
the United States we don't know and that
in and of itself may well be weaponized
we just don't know yet and there is
every indication Trump would try to
weaponize it preventing vote-by-mail etc
etc but this issue of wave 2 now is
starting to be written about and I think
this is really important there's a lot
of people that are thinking in six weeks
we're gonna be fully back to normal as
Anthony Fauci said things will not
really be back to normal until we have a
vaccine and that's not going to be until
2021 what else did I have oh okay this
is an article from the conservative
National Review and this article very
for political reasons argues that Sweden
did the right thing Sweden took a more
libertarian approach Sweden only did the
isolation for the at-risk people Sweden
left bars and restaurants open to a
great degree
Sweden continued to allow young people
to run rampant through the country the
idea being the young people would build
herd immunity maybe but the economy
would keep going and we would I salute
the most vulnerable people I don't know
whether it is or isn't working and I'll
explain why if we go back to our rural
dah meters dot info data and we look at
Sweden where is Sweden here Sweden right
now officially has 90 100 cases and
almost 800 deaths so right away you see
that Sweden has an almost 10% death rate
that doesn't strike me as working well
but at the same time Sweden isn't
testing very much
Sweden is testing even less than the
United States Sweden is taking a sort of
laser fair approach to some degree so
considering how little Sweden is testing
and the fact that they're isolating the
people that are more at risk and letting
young people sort of run wild
maybe Sweden has thirty thousand forty
fifty say I don't know what the number
would be a huge number of asymptomatic
or mild cases that never get tested
maybe Sweden's doing okay I just don't
know I think that the right-wing media
outlets that are promoting what Sweden
is doing from a libertarian ideological
perspective they don't really have the
data to make the call but I don't think
we have the data either because part of
what Sweden is doing is not testing
very much so I'd be I'd be interested in
seeing more actual data out of Sweden
data that we just don't have right now
so you can check out that article on
National Review which is of course a
biased right-wing publication and they
are reporting this for ideological
reasons last thing on therapeutics there
is a new study which is suggesting that
chloroquine from favourite treatment is
not working super well as you know I
have no fear of telling you about
chloroquine I told you about chloroquine
10 days before Trump did but I also told
you about a vegan
Ramdas aveer and a whole bunch of other
stuff
I'm not ideologically or emotionally
attached to any possible treatment we
have a new study that says chloroquine
really may not be working super well
there's a new idea that the tuberculosis
vaccine from a hundred years ago could
work against coronavirus not as a
vaccine per se important but because of
the immune system boosting effect that
the tuberculosis vaccine may have this
is being being looked at very strongly
here in Massachusetts this is dr. Denis
Faust 'men director of immuno biology at
Mass General in Boston one of the
premier medical institutions in the
country if not the world she has been
studying a tuberculosis vaccine known as
BCG and its effect on diabetes the idea
that the tuberculosis vaccine may boost
the immune response and be effective
against other conditions has been
studied for a long time by folks like
dr. Osmond and it is now being looked at
called the bacillus Calmette Garan
vaccine still being looked at now as
something that may it's not a vaccine
for coronavirus but it may have an
immune system boosting response which
could work scientists in melbourne
australia are using it versus placebo
folks were doing it right it's these are
proper studies you have to give a
placebo ideally it's randomized etc the
idea is test it for coronavirus versus a
placebo
now some people are
hangout you don't want an overactive
immune system that's absolutely true and
in fact we've seen some studies about
certain for lack of a better term
elements of medical I hate to use that
term but it's sort of appropriate here I
don't even want to name them because
there's also fake news spreading but
there we've seen a response in some
people where their immune system goes
overboard and it's not good for dealing
with coronavirus that's not the idea of
the tuberculosis vaccine is not to make
the immune system go overboard it's
merely to get it functioning in a way
that could reduce the likelihood of a
severe case of coronavirus it's being
tested it's being tested and again I
have no emotional attachment to any
particular any particular path on this I
am open to all open to all okay let me
say thank you to a bunch of people all
right
triple G dog has subscribed with prime
on Twitch 24 pounds has gifted a
subscription on Twitch qualia oh seven
has subscribed for nine months we have
very few nine months subscribers on
twitch but thank you
says Biden is gonna lose in the general
I don't know I'm not pretending to know
also want to say thanks to Twilight
crush and Kelly Nass for signing up on
Twitch I very much appreciate that okay
let's look at some of the super chats
that have been coming in let me see here
Daniel Rivera says friend James H loves
your show and he asked how is it we have
a growing stock market with 16 million
people unemployed two answers pick the
answer you like answer one is
speculation the stock market at this
point because of uncertainty is very
much subject to traders pushing it up
and down for their own benefit and it's
completely disconnected from what's
going on in the economy that's one
explanation the second explanation would
be the unemployment numbers were already
priced in if you believe in something
called efficient market theory which you
know it's like
some the thing about a lot of these
economics theories are that there is
some truth to them but they are not all
encompassing I believe that efficient
markets theory strictly speaking is
bogus but there is some some degree to
which it is it represents a reality if
you already anticipate 16 million losing
their jobs when you learn about that the
stock market goes down the stock market
then reflects the belief that there will
be sixteen million lost jobs so when we
get three and then six and then six the
stock market had already priced it in so
you don't necessarily in fact confirming
the estimates were right could push the
stock market back up I'm giving you like
neoclassical economic propaganda here to
be to be very clear but you know with
all with many of these economic theories
there is some truth but they are not
they are not perfect I don't remember
who it was that said it but if they're
there so it's some let me see if I can
find it a $20 bill efficient market
there's a funny I want to get this right
because ok there's an old story ok of
two people are walking down the street
one stops and says look there's a $20
bill on the ground the economist turns
and without looking down says not
possible if there was a $20 bill on the
ground somebody would have already
picked it up that is the epitome or a
microcosm of efficient market hypothesis
so in some cases it obviously is not is
not accurate and for all the people in
the chat saying David you're repeating
things that have been completely
disproven they've been disproven as
being 100% correct these are not invalid
theories but they simply don't represent
everything that we now know about
economics behavioral economics has
drastically changed our understanding of
a lot of these things ok if you're
joining me on Twitter
twitch YouTube or Facebook I have a new
thing that we are going to try today so
last week or so I've been limiting
myself during the streams to one pitch
for membership and it's been going well
but it's been diminishing a little bit
each day in the last 24 hours
I got emails from three people who had
very similar ideas and they essentially
came to me and they said David oh I can
lift my chair now that my hair has gone
down a little bit I can lift my chair I
was sitting a little too low before
people came to me this that they said
David you should do an experiment during
your next live stream you are certainly
starting to saturate the number of
website members on your stream because
you can only really sign up once it's
not totally true but most people are
only gonna sign up once on your website
and the minimum buy-in is two bucks a
month you should do one stream where you
only promote patreon for two different
reasons number one the buy-in on patreon
is just $1 a month if there's people if
there's some number of people who can
afford 2 bucks a month there's way more
people who can afford one dollar a month
so that's one reason the second idea was
you might come across a lot of people
who were already members but would still
make a patreon pledge to you so we're
gonna test that today I'm gonna mention
this one time you will notice that the
bar above my head today doesn't say
anything about website memberships all
it says is patreon patrons and the URL
is patreon.com slash david pakman show
it is true that there is a dollar
minimum so we lost three hundred and
eighty nine members unfortunately in
March because a lot of people are
struggling with the virus we've lost
several dozen already in April if you
appreciate the streams and you're not
down to your last dollar I don't want
anyone's last dollar consider going over
to patreon.com slash david pakman show
or just google david pakman show patreon
and you can pledge any amount you want
or just a single dollar I'm gonna thank
everybody we've never done this before
it truly could be an absolute disaster
there could be something special about
my audience where my audience hates
patreon I I don't know
and it could be an absolutely
embarrassing fiasco but I also heard
from people who said David you might be
able to hit a hundred patrons because a
lot of people have accounts already
and they'll very easily throw a dollar
at you so that is the request for today
patreon.com slash david pakman show
we're at zero no we're not I want to say
thanks to give give has made a pledge of
two bucks on patreon so we are at one
out of twenty five let's test it let's
test it and see and you may very quickly
see me back to never mentioning patreon
again on tomorrow stream if it doesn't
go well okay other super chats coming in
Sebastian Wilkins says looks like the
isolation is getting to David it's it is
getting to me but I'm just I don't have
anywhere to go to get a haircut and why
even bother shaving you know like what's
the point this is the this is the best
beard I've ever been able to grow it's
pathetic my testosterone is fine it's
been checked it has nothing to do with
that it's just this is the beard this is
the beard so it's it's not so much that
it's getting to me I'm just I'm just
living living with it day by day each
day I wake up and I say should I shave
today and then I said of course not what
why would I shave it doesn't make any
sense
mekka 101 says let's get hashtag kovat
19 hair trending Paul JM says could you
comment on claims that the w-h-o is
biased towards China love the show yeah
I mean there just seemed to be at least
some evidence that the w-h-o is uh is
China centric the right word as Donald
Trump said I don't know Paris here and
says birthrate I think that's a Freudian
slip are you girlfriend Moody just
kidding love from Sweden thank you pair
Donna Williams says obese patients have
a more time read if achill time
recovering from any respiratory illness
I'm an RT respiratory therapist thank
you for all you do
very interesting Donna very interesting
Waller is me says Sweden less tests per
capita fewer more deaths per capita
compared to the US Trump wouldn't
understand this
like I mentioned before let's see here
Steven Kenneth destiny banal who is
really the user formerly known as Hugh
Jass who is really the user formerly
known as Alex Jones is again telling me
about you know things related to destiny
and all the stuff I don't care you know
whatever you know do say say whatever
you want I'm not worried about it
um what else do we have here oh I missed
a bunch Matthew
vist and Daisy says Australia is close
to a vaccine checkout difference between
compartmental models and agents agents
based models by James Janssen yet
there's a lot of places that are closed
but the human testing takes a while
alright let's thank some patrons here
this is going to be very exciting we're
doing a test a patron only test today
let me say thank you to cull ah oh boy
we're already in trouble
Kolani hella Cooney he oh boy
is patron number two today Mario and
Christina our patrons number three
Charlie Kelly is patron number four
piano man is patron number five Raphael
Marin is patron number six today Rachael
Gerstner is patron number seven
Austin Clark is patron number eight
today Kelly Barnes is patron number nine
baby and Peterson is patron number ten
today
scarlet Babylon is patron number eleven
Robert clobber see the advantage that
patreon is people more frequently use
handles instead of real name so you get
things like Robert clobber who's patron
number twelve mystique lady is patron
number thirteen
Edie Spencer is number fourteen ernesto
Fidalgo whoops I think I did something
wrong there number fifteen there we go
got it Ernesto that was my grandfather's
name Ernesto Fidalgo is number fifteen
Melanie broan of is new is a new patron
number six
today Epona's tribe is new patron number
17 and ellas ayo Alvarez is new patron
number 18 we're doing a one-day test
we're instead of memberships we're doing
patreon pledges at patreon.com slash
david pakman show we are standing by for
today's White House coronavirus press
briefing scheduled originally for 5:00
p.m. Eastern rescheduled for 6:00 p.m.
Eastern let me see if Donald Trump has
tweeted anything about it nope Trump's
last tweet was about the Wall Street
Journal being fake news fake news of
course a favorite phrase of the
president let me say thank you to Bernie
Cohn Murray who has gifted a
subscription on Twitch as well as Jean
Stein Willie and p-funk apocalypse all
of whom have subscribed over on Twitch
prime I had a couple other things that I
wanted to go over with you guys let me
see if I can find them here I'm pulling
up my notes and where is it okay here it
is yeah so we've got a clip coming out
about this later today
Republican congressman Dan Crenshaw was
interviewed by Joe Rogan and Crenshaw
just completely imploded on the issue of
health care and this is really good
let's see if we can go through a little
bit of this and we're gonna try to pick
apart some of the very very bad
arguments that were made we have plenty
of time until the press conference
starts so let's check this out let's
take a look at it it tries to move past
these essential foundations whether of a
free society that we have to adhere to
and and because the other thing I I push
back on a little bit is the health care
as a right statement and I push back
against that because with that when
you're calling something a right what
you're effectively saying is that
somebody else has a obligation to serve
you and it's hard to call
something right when that so that should
remind you of Rand Paul libertarian
Senator Rand Paul has said you make
doctors slaves with single-payer right
requires the service of somebody else
don't don't we already do that with the
firemen don't we do that with the police
department don't we do that with public
schools not exactly no I mean we have
public services that I would I would
distinguish those public services from
something like a reckless quantum of
care and I would distinguish them to it
to an enormous extent like but here's
why you can add a few hundred thousand
more people to a you know to to the
nation's population and it doesn't
change the mission of the military right
like it doesn't it doesn't take an away
thing away from them but these but
because of this sort of non-rival this
is like an economics term but this sort
of non-rival attribute of these things
it is different so right because now
he's arguing and pay this is important
Dan Crenshaw is arguing that health care
is not a public good in the same way
that all of these other things are and
that health care as a right would reduce
freedom in some way now this is bogus
you have a right to an attorney you have
a right to an attorney
that doesn't mean any one attorney is
enslaved by needing to represent you but
you have a right to one attorney when
you are accused regardless of your
ability to pay our lawyers slaves at
this point no and in the same way we
already have you know if you go to an
emergency room there's a law from 1986
which says the the the hospital has to
provide stabilizing emergency treatment
for you whether or not you can pay I
have doctors been slaved since 1986 No
so this is a terrible argument and now
Crenshaw starts to fall apart and he
goes into Gish Gallup which is when you
throw a bunch of different arguments at
the wall to see what sticks there's only
a select number of doctors and we've
already said that once you put price
controls in there's going to be less
doctors because doctors will be paid
less they'll get burned out more they'll
then Possible's we'll be able to
actually never finish that point
the reason price controls reduce supply
and we reason we see supply reductions
in other countries is because well
hospitals don't get the so notice how
without joe rogan really doing anything
he has shifted from saying medicare for
all reduces freedom to medicare for all
does other things it'll reduce the
available supply of hell he's going into
totally unrelated argument same amount
of money they're not too invested in
that extra ICU bet they're not gonna buy
those extra ventilators they're not
gonna hire those other doctors a doctor
doesn't want to be a doctor because they
don't make the amount of money that they
thought they would make their so now
we've got a third argument which is
doctor compensation would be a problem
under medicare for all notice how listen
these are all hypothetically valid
things to talk about other countries
have figured all of them out but the
argument was about freedom that imploded
he's now on arguments three and four
doing extra work because there's more
people who now have access to them but
there's less of them so wait lines are
huge and then and they're seeing
multiple more patients a day so now
we've shift understand so the term I
used was Gish Gallup gifs Gallup is when
you throw a whole bunch of stuff at
someone and it's too crazy either
because of time limits or practicality
to really think through each of them and
keep them separate he's now into wait
times again talking about wait times is
not invalid but they're now on the
fourth or fifth different argument
doctor burnout increases quite a bit
that's the quick answer and now he's
talking about doctor burnout as to why
why why that happens but does that kind
of answer your question no getting
really that does yeah the human right
issue we we kind of moved around with
that so Joe Rogan correctly pointing out
what happened to the real issue we were
talking about that this the idea that
it's different than the fire department
or the police department or well it's
not a right either actually the the fire
department's not necessarily a a right
as we would but it's a public service
that's provided to him now and you're
gonna see this continued crenshaw shifts
to some very pedantic semantic arguments
about what we call things code so if if
those aren't really rights then when we
say health care is a right
maybe we also aren't literally saying
it's a right but we consider it a public
good now he's getting into semantics
distortions it is but it but it but
understand so let's call it a public
service then and let's call doctor
healthcare a public service that's what
Joe was suggesting five minutes ago when
you said it was different okay if we
were to do Medicare for all but wasn't
the result be the same if it's provided
for everyone not from a practical
standpoint just because it's much easier
again you could add a hundred thousand
people more to your city and the fire
department would have marginally more
more work to do so now that's not an
argument about principle understand and
you know I know that this stuff it's
even difficult to follow it because it's
all over the place he has gone from an
ideological argument about Medicare for
all or single-payer reduce freedom and
effectively enslave doctors to now
saying it would just be practically
difficult difficult because there'd be a
lot more people who want health care
that's a completely different argument
it's a it's an unrelated argument you
know compared to like a doctor for
instance does that make sense like just
it doesn't I think on a if we're trying
to compare them in that sense that that
non-rival attributes matter it matters
quite a bit faster I think he keeps
slipping in non non rival is an economic
term and I think he keeps slipping it in
because he suspects Joe Rogan's not
gonna engage with it probably because
it's not a term Joe knows it's not even
I mean okay so it's a common economic
term to some degree but it's not like
it's not so that it's common a supply
and demand right or elasticity and I
think he keeps mentioning it to try to
circumvent like listen you don't even
understand what this term means so we're
not really gonna be able to engage I
mean that so what you're saying is
because competition is necessary with
medical innovation and also like doctors
profit off of being exceptional so you
you they have incentive to be
exceptional no no what I'm saying is if
you have if you have ten doctors that's
that are serving a community every time
that doctor is serving somebody it means
somebody else can't see them
well isn't that just
a signal that we need more doctors and
more hospitals today and not only that
again I want to remind everybody there's
a 1986 law I have it here called the
emergency medical treatment and active
Labor Act mandates hospitals provide
stabilizing emergency treatment to
patients and baby delivery services to
women in active labor no matter whether
they can pay
why isn't Dan Crenshaw why aren't all of
them saying that the 1986 an emergency
medical treatment Act enslaves doctors
if a woman comes in in labor and they
have to provide her baby delivery
services someone else isn't getting
treatment right I mean that's the
argument and no one is going after the
1986 Act because of course it doesn't
actually enslave doctors now let me skip
forward a little bit here where they get
into some completely delusional stuff
and they it just becomes a semantic
debate here we go right so we're talking
about over what you're talking about
socialism overall not just over I'm not
just involving medicine you're talking
about socialism in general and I'm
saying isn't the fire department an
example of socialism that works it's not
an example of socialism I think it's an
example of a public good the way the
military is an example of a public good
the way the highways are examples of
public goods the way parks are exam
right but they're funded by the people
it's funded by people overall it doesn't
cost people money to use them and the
people have these as a basic part of our
society and our civilization I
understand that and nothing wrong with
that I just I just would not call them
socialists would I call the fire how
does it get funded it's a public good
how does it get funded it's a public
good it gets funded by the public right
and it's just it's not it's but it's not
relying on these sort of it's not
relying on the tenants of socialism to
function and so now we're now we're kind
of having a discussion of definitions
and this is an important discussion to
have because oftentimes even Democrats
aren't really talking about socialism
why even Germany Sanders is in college
that's exactly right
so we've come completely back around to
a conversation that is merely about the
Able's and he's considering conceding
really none of this stuff is actually
socialist it's so just circular and Joe
what I what I think is interesting about
this is that Joe Rogan describes himself
not as a politics guy he says he's
interested in politics but that he's not
in fact he was very nice and yesterday
said I'm a politics guy and he named a
few other people so Joe Rogan isn't
reacting with talking points he's
reacting with you know Dan what you're
saying really doesn't make any sense and
it's a genuine reaction and that's what
it's just so fascinating about this I
haven't watched I really only watch this
section here which producer Pat had
flagged for me and we have a segment on
it coming out later but very very you
know all of these arguments just very
quickly falling apart under just basic
questioning basic questioning from Joe
Rogan okay let me thank a bunch of other
patrons today let me see where we are
okay Nick Harper is new patron number 19
today we're going for a hundred lunch
money is new patron number twenty today
basil Choudhary is new new patron number
twenty one today Linda Garth is number
twenty two Carol just Carol is new
member a new patron number twenty-three
Charles Hess is new patron number 24 Amy
is new patron number 25 on that note I'm
just gonna we're just going for a
hundred and if we fail it'll be
embarrassing Jay Jay Hitchcock is new
patron number 26 Kim lukannon is new
patron twenty-seven Jose Bruna is number
28 Beverly Webber is number 29 Maureen
Henry is number thirty fail odd is new
patron number 31 Trevor Patterson is
number 32 Lynn kibble mom love that is
number 33 Zachary Monroe is number 34
Aaron Madsen is new patron number 35
Lila
oming is patron number 36 true istic
prince is new patron 37 and christie
jones is new patron number 38 love it
very very compelling stuff okay other
questions and super chats coming in
brodie Andrew Mulligan says Thank You
Pat max and Noah love from Dallas
thanks Brody I'll tell you're a Wilson
says can you tell me what Louisiana is
doing per capita yeah let's take a look
let's take a look at Louisiana okay
USA so in terms of cases per population
Louisiana is third with 3900 in terms of
deaths per population Louisiana is also
third and in terms of tests per
population Louisiana is doing a lot of
testing 18,000 almost as much as New
York the more testing per capita the
more closely those numbers mirror-like
the full scope of what is going on
within any particular state david pakman
Germany branch office headquarters says
hey David could ever someone with
similar personality like Angela Merkel
become President of the United States
Congrats to your excellent show I mean
listen if someone with Trump's
personality can become president I would
not pretend to know that any particular
personality would be off-limits for the
presidency thanks to William Kennedy
Zach Williams says just watched your
video about Bernie dropping I agree with
you
1 million percent have $5 yes if you're
if you're watching on YouTube right now
please hit like and subscribe before you
do anything else but we do have a
20-minute video that I published about
an hour and a half ago on YouTube where
I talk about the Bernie Biden Trump
situation and I encourage everybody to
check it out thanks to maarten van Gorp
who says cuz you deserve it cameron
wealthy has signed up danny thompson
says people receiving the federal
unemployment 600 per week here in
minnesota my 30-plus years in tax need
to give a warning this money as well as
any state money will be reported to the
IRS on a 1099 G 1200 dollar stimulus is
not taxable unemployment is yes very
important so let's let's break this down
I'm gonna provide you guys with some
some data the there was a rumor a very
nasty nasty rumor that was spreading
that the $1200 stimulus money is taxable
as income on your 2020 tax return this
is not true what's going to happen is
that on your 2020 tax return if I
understand correctly and I'm guessing
Danny can correct me if I'm wrong the
1200 dollars in stimulus will be
reported as money coming in and you will
get a $1200 credit meaning it is not
taxable every dollar of that money you
get back as a credit so it's a wash it's
a way to report it and to keep track of
who has received the money so for a
while there was a rumor that it's just
gonna be taxable you're gonna owe your
you're gonna owe income tax on the
$1,200 that is not true it was a nasty
nasty rumor but it is not true
unemployment insurance is taxable
unemployment insurance is taxable as
income you will need to report it
some states give you the option of
having taxes withheld from your
unemployment money as if it was you know
w2 income or whatever the case may be it
is conceivable that the government could
do any number of one-time things so you
know if the standard deduction is
$12,000 you know the government could
say for the 2020 tax year the standard
deduction is $18,000 that would exempt
an additional few thousand dollars that
people may have received in unemployment
or not like the government could do
things like that but the $1,200 stimulus
is not
it'll be a wash because of the credit
unemployment insurance income is taxable
now the only thing I don't know is is
unemployment insurance income always
taxable at the state level well I guess
certain states don't have income tax at
all I'm guessing in those states it
would not be taxable are there any
states with an income tax that exempt
unemployment income from taxation I
don't know the answer to that I don't
know the answer to that
Jamal Swift says hey homie hey Jamal
appreciate the support
Shannon Bennis says so strange that
right-wing media has seized on
hydroxychloroquine it is Greg Oliver has
signed up Keaton Klepper says David
would you vote for Borat if he was DNC
candidate no I am NOT a vote blue no
matter who person I am a I'm a person
who evaluates the candidates and says
who do I prefer so when I say I'm voting
for Biden over Trump I am NOT saying
vote blue no matter who I'm saying I
know who the options are it's Trump or
Biden and I prefer Biden I prefer Biden
on the environment I prefer Biden on
judges I prefer Biden on taxes
I prefer Biden on diplomacy etc etc I
don't subscribe to vote blue no matter
who pear tieran says I would rather give
in this format Bryan Watson says keep it
up Mike Henderson says if anyone ever
says the economy is great because the
stock market is up we have 16 million
people unemployed and the stock market
is going every day fair point
oh these scrolled past me nico Suman
then says here's a comparison of deaths
between nordic countries and the u.s. if
that serves a purpose for you David
let's take a look at that okay so yeah
that that is that is interesting and
that so we've got confirmed deaths and
Daly confirmed deaths total confirmed
deaths and Daly the US has more of both
now is that is this per population it
doesn't seem it doesn't seem to be per
population and it's a log scale I don't
like this data guys this is not that's
nasty data I don't think that that's the
right visualization for me okay let me
say thanks to a few other patreon
patrons let me say thank you to loopy
loopy noops Esquire who is new patron
number 39 today Alf arias Omegan is new
patron number 40 MS Marquette is new
patron number 41 Alex Stevenson is new
patron number 42 we're skipping
membership today I didn't freeze I'm not
even allowed to talk about membership
today we're only talking about patreon
Alec Stevenson is patron number 42 James
Rainey is new patron 43 Ringo is new
patron 44 AC is new patron number 45 Ian
Cooper is new patron number 46 Sandra a
guest is number 47 Judith Rice is new
patron number 48 yarrow studio is 49
Lisa MW is number 50 Luna kill we now we
kill we and now we oboe is new patron
number 51 Alicia Baker is number 52 and
Molly Curran is number 53 thanks so much
guys very much appreciate it we're it's
a it's a beta test very much beta I I'd
actually call it an alpha test we are
just doing doing patreon today also want
to say thanks to fizz wery for
subscribing over on Twitch and dinosaur
Cal who says who is the guy with the eye
patch this is congressman
oh the eyepatch guy this is congressman
dan Crenshaw who was interviewed two
days ago I guess it was by
Joe Rogan the room is starting to fill
up and we are getting closer and closer
to today's White House press briefing
let's see if Donald Trump has tweeted
any update nope still scheduled for 6:00
p.m. as near as I can tell I will not be
with you for the full briefing today
being Thursday I am going to have to cut
out a little early because I've got this
there's this great French bistro that I
go to dinner at on Thursdays and
obviously I'm kidding I'm not leaving my
house but I have a few things going on
so I will stay as long as I can
hopefully they get started pretty soon
Raphael M says I'm a member on the
website twitch prime and now on patreon
keep up the great work thanks Raphael
Helen Frater says member from the UK I
feel for you regarding the mental health
of your current president's president he
is a nut job
to be frank Safra geum says please
elaborate the w-h-o is partial to china
listen III don't know that we can trust
the data out of China
I just don't I'm questioning whether we
can at this point that that's all and I
am not really ready to take a stronger
stronger position than that Henrick
Mullins says you are my guilty pleasure
evening entertainment why guilty
pleasure that makes it sound bad makes
this sound like Tiger king Adrian
Strecker says I love the idea of you
going on Rogan again if so could you
have talked to him about having Sam see
Dhahran - that would be awesome for
progressives zip jay says you should
develop a Trump drinking game maybe take
a drink when he says tremendous I'm
pretty sure drinking any kind of
drinking games are not allowed certainly
on Twitch or maybe it you can't like
drinking for subscriptions is not
allowed I'm gonna stay away from any
drinking related stuff I don't know that
it's the right move for my channel name
withheld says hey David great show I'm
not a doctor but kovat seems like a very
aggravated form of COPD research it more
don't take my word
Beverly Webber says just joined your
patreon love good content thank you
Thank You Beverly Jen and NYX says why
does Alberta oil always get left out of
the topic of trade US Empire and coke
interest has shaped Canadian politics
for decades your military at the border
Trump's rhetoric and exclusion scares me
is that irrational fear of Trump is
never irrational I don't know enough
about the Alberta oil situation to
really comment intelligently Lorenzo
Carillo says we are in a fight for our
lives the incompetency of Donald Trump
and the GOP is tearing our country to
shreds and one day your unborn children
and grandchildren will pay for this mess
no joke this is real bulky a writer says
do you think some of the primaries were
rigged
Kyle kolinsky flirted with the idea I
don't have evidence that makes me
believe that at this point in time Chad
durka wits a real chad reed by that i
mean literally a real chad the arizona
governor isn't taking this seriously
most businesses are still open yeah I
have a bunch of friends in Arizona and
many of them well if in fact uh I know
several people who recently moved there
and I'm hearing the exact same thing and
it is very very ugly very very ugly let
me thank a few other new patrons Jason
Kaiser is new member number 54 there's a
few things better than a kaiser roll I
don't know if there's any familial
background there Aiden Bouchard is new
patron number 55 today Tina Ross is new
patron number 56
Phaedra keet is new patron number 57
Lance Smith is number 58 today and
Harold Powers is number 59 I think I
have a few other new patrons to thank
Phantom Jam is number 60 today it's an
all patreon stream Lou no grass is
number 61 Corey miner is number 62 Seth
banana
the second okay is number 63 Johnathan's
salata is new patron number 64 Tim
Arnold is number 65 w Calhoun is new
patron 66 and team Aitken is number 67
today we are two-thirds of the way to
today's goal amazing stuff okay other
super chats coming in as we stand by for
the president
Tony herring says shouldn't the
president be more like the star
quarterback rather than a cheerleader on
the sidelines I surprised I'm surprised
people aren't pointing this out more
yeah I don't need the president to be so
front and center when it comes to
coronavirus response I would want the
president essentially standing by
respectfully and letting the doctors
speak if that were the case we would
have heard from Anthony foutch earlier
this week rather than Donald Trump
cutting him off about chloroquine in
fact let me see if I can find like this
should never happen me find the video
for you Trump pouchy chloroquine
question this happened I think it was on
Tuesday where is that from pouchy maybe
it's just Trump voci chloroquine I can
find it um where was that I'm having
trouble finding it right now but in any
case earlier this week Donald Trump
interrupted and told a reporter to stop
asking that question when Anthony foul G
was asked what do you think about
chloroquine of course
Anthony thought you should have been
allowed to answer a sensible president
would have allowed it
JR says an aside what is it about chess
you find so attractive I've been wanting
to learn for awhile and now is probably
a good time you know I couldn't really
say I just I enjoy playing it it's
completely different than my day-to-day
work so I've just gotten into it the
last year and a half or so let's see
here
Stephen Kenneth destiny bonel asks how
much will it cost me for you to crap
destiny I am NOT going to start
criticizing you know people on YouTube
whose content
I haven't even watched do demean
subscribes Andrew Hodge says please turn
the Crenshaw analysis into a segment it
is in fact a segment version of what I
just talked about with Dan Crenshaw is
now a YouTube clip 14 minutes long which
is available for sharing and
disseminating sharing and disseminating
stance Pringle says please pull down
Crenshaw bit out as its own video I just
did see Cruz says you should add nasty
question for bingo we had I believe it
is on there or we had it for a while I
am a NICU RN do you know how many babies
have families with zero insurance the
state ends up paying for them so I have
no problem with Medicare for all very
important point you know when we talk
when people like Dan Crenshaw say
Medicare for all would explode demand
well it would shift a lot of it from
emergency rooms to primary care from
acute treatment to preventive treatment
yeah it's it's a very very bad argument
let me say thank you to shaggy
8ball shaggy 8ball is new patron number
68 today Chris Reuter is new patron
number 69
Lawrence Burns is new patron number 70
today David Ross man is new patron
number 71 unvexed is new patron number
72 today adele Burbridge is new patron
number 73
Gulliver Braun is new patron number 74
Peter Faria is new patron 75 and
Kimberly Smith is new patron number 76
people are starting to file into the
press briefing room we see a lot of
masks today for sure and I guess we're
sort of getting close to the start of
today's briefing matrix asks what
software do I use for my streams I use
stream labs OBS it's free
it's it's quite good Connor Brenner says
this is what drives me insane about
Crenshaw he's so disingenuous and his
arguments are always in bad faith I hate
that Pete Davidson apologized to him and
gave him this platform he now enjoys I
actually know nothing about that I'm not
familiar with that
Keaton Klepper says are you a
constructivist realist or liberal in
political science
okay hybrid I've studied all three and I
am a hybrid Andy Johnson says take the
like button to the cleaners folks thanks
yeah if you're watching on YouTube
remember the likes and the subscribes
are free free completely free they are
as free as Jim Acosta x' questions to
trump are nasty questions so remember to
pound the like button and pound the
subscribe button it really uh it really
helps us Andrew Morgan has Greta sent to
super chat Timothy S says all the ads I
get from your channel are from epoch
times
yeah a bunch of people have been telling
me about that of course we have very
little control over that
Sven Olson has subscribed Paul JM says
done the L cheeto where is the cheeto
he's late as usual late as usual
Gordon cook says hey David Brody Andrew
Mulligan says is kovat 19 affecting your
garden and fresh Bistro tomato no so I
just put in a very strong powerful order
for a bunch of gardening stuff this I'm
actually just we could be days from me
starting to do planting so here in
Boston I am ready to plant outdoors
radishes carrots and snow peas all will
be planted outdoors very very powerfully
indoors I'm about to start
tomatoes both red and yellow grape with
grape or cherry cherry tomatoes a
variety of herbs
and what all sigh starting inside
tomatoes oh and some spicy peppers I'm
going to be starting inside because it's
still a little early to move those
outdoors my horticulturist friend said
Mother's Day Mother's Day is when you
can move a lot of those outside so we're
gonna get that going
I've been looking at it very strongly
and now the only thing is I need a cubic
yard of soil and I think that the bags
are usually three-quarters of a
something so I need my friend said I
would need thirty six bags of soil which
is nuts so I need to call a landscaper
and say can you just bring me like with
a some kind of truck can you bring me a
full cubic yard of soil because that's
what I'm gonna need for my raised beds
okay let me thank a few other people big
thank you - oh boy I hope I pronounced
this correctly
oh no okay this is simple Samantha
Sabatino is new patron number 77 today
Vanessa Hendricks is number 78
Andrea fee Ando is number 79
Pedro Miramon is number 80 M Jay
Pritchett is patron number 81
Brian kortner is number 82 mushrooms is
number 83 oh boy Deena Rey is patron
number 84 black-eyed Dilli is new member
new patron number 85 stress nugget is
number 86 Michael Turner is number 87
Jenna Kashmiri Kashmir is number 88 and
David chlorin is number 89 guys we're
getting dangerously close to a hundred
new patrons today which would be bonkers
absolutely completely bonkers okay The
Apprentice says I hear it's amazing when
the famous purple stuffed warm in flap
Jos bass with the tuning fork does a Rob
link on harakiri rock I don't know a
thing about that I really couldn't tell
you Thomas says
what war do you think Biden will start
in 2021 I I don't think so I just don't
think so Alan says are you still doing
chess games yeah we haven't done a
tournament for a little while but I am
still playing chess myself Catherine I
allure has subscribed on YouTube let's
see here Steven Kenneth destiny bunnell
says how much for a destiny debate over
medicare-for-all I I don't know Chris K
says are we starting soon you know I
certainly hope so people are filing in
we've got Jim Acosta here we have
another reporter kind of this is she
actually kind of looks like Libby Libby
something from Washington Post but I
don't think that's who that is and we've
got our friend from Bloomberg here and I
forgot this guy's name but yeah it does
look like we're getting ready to start
soon let's see if Trump has updated his
Twitter now still scheduled for 6:00
p.m. as far as I know so we'll see how
that all goes
thanks to Craig st. for signing up on
YouTube Samantha Sabatino says I'm here
for my daily dose of nasty questions
Thank You Deepak Thank You Stu guys say
says do you think Joe Biden likes Cheers
I really couldn't tell you G Bradbury
says is it fair to say the u.s. is not
really a democracy as long as lobbyists
and special interest groups can
basically buy elections well the u.s. is
actually categorized as a flawed
democracy flawed democracy so in a sense
it is true that we are not a full
democracy full rocker says loving the
constant incite keep up the good work
Emmit says David my keyboard is broken
from pounding the subscribe button and
this super chat is costing me my
keyboard replacement money hashtag worth
it I have been recommended very strongly
someone once saw in a behind-the-scenes
video that I have this wireless keyboard
and it's terrible it's really not a
comfortable keyboard to type on and a
bunch of people wrote to me saying David
you really need a mechanical keyboard
and I am now can
during a make mechanical keyboard very
very strongly and a lot of people with
different opinions about which is the
right one and it would be great to have
a wireless because the thing is my
computer is kind of far so the great
thing about this is it's wireless I also
have a wireless mouse I would be more
inclined to get a mechanical keyboard if
I could get a good wireless one but they
are as people are pointing out they are
kind of loud they may not be appropriate
for they may be uncouth or not decorous
for live streams so that's something I
definitely I'm gonna have to think about
okay uh other I've got a bunch of other
people to thank here Gabrielle Steinman
is new patron number ninety today thanks
Gabrielle
David mcknight is new patron number 91
guys we may be able to do it
David Jackman his new patron number 92
Zooey Ferguson is number 93 Ben cone is
number 94 Matt Nagel is number 95
Sven Olson is number 96 Eva feller is
number 97 and that is it we are three
patrons away can you imagine three
patrons away from 100 100 is a big big
number it's not millions or billions but
it's certainly a big big number okay if
you were just joining me I'm realizing
that there are people who are now
joining because it's again the top of
the hour we were originally scheduled
for a 5 p.m. livestream it was postponed
until 6 p.m. here on the East Coast and
it is now 6 p.m. it is in fact now 602
p.m. so we anticipate that this is going
to get started any moment we don't know
anything about why it's been postponed
again we will just sort of run through
the numbers very very quickly the
official number of coronavirus cases
glow
is just shy of 1.6 million and we are
sadly approaching 100,000 deaths the
United States continues to be number one
with more than three times as many cases
as any other country we are up to 1,700
deaths today yesterday we had 1940 it
would be great if we could see a
reduction still many hours left in the
day and it is unclear if that's going to
happen the official full numbers here
463 thousand cases 16 thousand five
hundred deaths on new york and new
jersey by far leading the pack michigan
is seeing pretty significant
acceleration in cases so are we here in
Massachusetts of course we are testing a
lot a lot a lot a lot and the Cova 19 I
am a model has not been updated today
the latest data that we have still
expects a peak formally three days from
today on April 12th and it expects
60,000 deaths 60,000 deaths in this
first wave of the corona virus a few
things that we talked about earlier and
I would encourage you to check these out
one is that there is more and more
information that obesity is a major
kovat 19 risk factor that's an article
you can check out on Reuters by gear de
Klerk we need to be increasingly mindful
of the second wave of kovat 19 that is
likely coming our way many articles
about that including this one in The
Lancet by Jean King Xu which I encourage
you to check out we are trying to get
more information about Sweden a lot of
right-wingers very excited excited about
Sweden's more libertarian policy but
they do officially have nearly a 10%
death rate right now and there is
information about the possibility of the
tuberculosis vaccine may be being
effective in bolstering the body's
immune system not as a as an actual
vaccination against coronavirus but
potentially as something that can boost
the immune system not in an in a crazy
way but enough that it may make the
immune system more resistant so
coronavirus and we are tracking that
very very closely okay let me say thank
you to oh I think we're about to crush
100 this is gonna be beautiful okay
Bradley Ward is new patron number 98
today wait a second did I think Bradley
already know I didn't katherine Eyler is
new patron number 99 and i am thrilled
to say that connor Brennan Brenner is
new patron number 100 and we're
continuing David Balfour is new patron
number 101 Armin pecks oven is new
patron number 102 today Darren Clarke is
new patron number 1:03
Zachary Winston is new patron number 104
and Christopher hellström is new patron
number 105 you know I've got to thank
those three people who emailed me
yesterday and said David just try doing
a patron goal just try doing a patron
goal because you might have saturated
membership a little bit people can get
in at only a dollar on patreon it could
work you might be able to get a hundred
new patrons in one stream and we did it
we did it now we just have to suffer
through Trump's lies for 40 minutes okay
I am not yet seeing any updates about
the scheduling I see some people in the
chat wondering if this has been further
delayed I don't believe that it has and
judging from the activity in the room it
does seem like we are getting closer
closer to the start okay
somebody said 6:30 do we have any actual
announcements announcements that say
6:30 because I'm not finding anything
that says it's 6:30 today I'm still
seeing 6 o'clock or people just trolling
me maybe nobody really knows okay I
think we are still scheduled little bit
of an announcement
Trump has Korona that delayed it I don't
think so per CNN interesting ok very
good
uh-oh you know what actually I'm gonna
need to as many of you know I'm working
out of a home studio I'm actually going
to need to do something to a couple of
systems that I have here if this is not
starting until 6:30 c-span says 6:30 at
the bottom of the screen let's see here
this one says starting soon c-span still
says 5:00 p.m. okay
I'm gonna black myself out momentarily
I'm gonna take care of two things and
then I'll be right back to pick it back
up we'll stand by in the room with Jim
Acosta momentarily
you
all right everybody I'm back it is
pouring here and I had a bunch of
packages sitting right out front which
unfortunately are soaked but I did bring
them in refresh my water and we are
ready to go originally scheduled for
five p.m. Eastern then rescheduled for 6
p.m. Eastern then apparently rescheduled
for closer to 6:30 p.m. Eastern and
apparently starting very very soon a
welcome we are still live on Twitter
twitch YouTube and Facebook as we have
been now for weeks and weeks of all of
this we will see what sorts of questions
we get today from Donald Trump and the
entire thing let me say a few other
thank-yous as many of you know I have
zipped my mouth I have not mentioned
membership today we're doing a patreon
pledge drive I want to say thanks to
Marcus Friddle who's patron number 106
today Jeffery Alami who is number 107
Kiana Lea DeLong is number one zero
eight Elizabeth will Holt is patron
number 109 Carolyn Chasteen is number
110 Heather Donaldson is number one one
one and Dave Campbell Dave Campbell is
number 112 thanks to all of you very
much appreciate very much appreciate
that support okay
there is dr. anthony foul she dr.
deborah birx and a guy i don't recognize
and soon we will likely hear from Donald
Trump let's see if we have any other
feeds in the room we do I always prefer
the feed where they cut to the reporters
when the reporters ask a question so you
may see me switched feeds once we get
started okay I like to see you know the
reporter as well so we know who's saying
what but that should
just Oh hearing some talking in the room
that should not be a problem Oh Trump's
coming out already over here so let's
let's switch over to this one thank you
very much everybody I'd like to begin by
saying that we just completed a meeting
with the Secretary of Treasury Steve
minuchin and Secretary of Transportation
Elaine Chao on proposals regarding the
airlines and the airline business and
we're very working very closely with a
lot of different people will be probably
putting out a proposal in giving them
some of the details from some of the
very powerful details power over the
weekend it's moving along quickly the
airline business has been hit very hard
as everybody knows and we are going to
be in a position to do a lot to help
them so that they keep their employees
and they save their businesses and
that'll be taking place I think you can
say over the weekend we may even have
discussions with some of the airlines or
all of the airlines over the weekend and
I think it's going to be a very
acceptable package it's a very big
package you'd have a very acceptable
package it'll be good for our country
good for the airlines good for a lot of
people likewise I just spoke with the
president of Russia
oh god Emir Putin king of Saudi Arabia
oh no King Salman more concluding talk
as to oil production and OPEC and making
it so that our industry does well and
the oil industry does better than it's
doing right now it's industry the
numbers are so low that there'll be
layoffs all over the world they'll be
certainly layoffs in this country we
don't want that to happen we built a
great great energy business in the
United States we should be off oil so we
have tens of thousands of jobs we had a
very good talk we'll see what happens
but as you know OPEC met today and I
would say they're getting close to a
deal we'll soon find out so that was a
conversation we just had so we've had a
busy hour and a half
and let me begin by expressing my
sincere gratitude to the American people
millions of Americans are making
profound and difficult sacrifices in
their own lives because they know it
will save the lives of countless others
and that's exactly what it's doing you
see what's happening and where we are
where we stand and hopefully we're going
to be opening up we can quote opening
very very very very soon I hope together
our people are writing one of the most
noble chapters in the proud history of
our nation Americans are also encouraged
to learn that Boris Johnson Prime
Minister has been moved out of intensive
care that's a tremendous statement and
we continue to pray for him and his fast
recovery that's a very very positive
development as the New York metropolitan
area continues its battle against the
outbreak the full power of the federal
government is there to support them as
you know the Javits Center has now been
fully converted into a 3,000 bed
hospital one of the largest anywhere in
the country and by the incredible
professionals I have to say the the
Corps of Engineers what they can do is
just incredible they've done a fantastic
job and they're building nationwide 21
temporary hospitals and care facilities
adding 17,000 hospital beds and they did
that all within a very short period of
time it's incredible what they've done
Army Corps of Engineers and FEMA has
been fantastic our sweeping airlift
operation to keep doctors and nurses
supplied with protective equipment
project air bridge continues to expand
with more than 24 flights already
completed and 49 additional flights now
scheduled in the near future so that's
been very successful in that gear and
those outfits are being handed out out
as they arrived they're going directly
to point the American medical system
continues to perform beyond our highest
expectations reminding us that the
United States is blessed with the most
advanced health care and the most
skilled health care workers anywhere in
the planet other countries are looking
to what would
in our testing operation has now become
far and away the most sophisticated and
the best anywhere wrong and we want to
thank all of the heroes or the
frontlines as they fight to save
American lives we're at the top of the
hill remember tech we're 43rd globally
and tests per capita downward in some
cases we've already started that process
earlier today I spoke with hundreds of
mental health leaders and advocates from
around the country to discuss the vital
work and the vital work they're doing we
had the top doctors in the country some
international doctors mental health a
big factor not only as the virus
inflicted immense physical suffering on
many people but also mental and
emotional suffering as well even though
we're staying physically apart no
American is alone and we're all in this
together but the mental health doctors
and experts a very great call it was a
very interesting call they're working
very hard we're also seeing encouraging
signs in our race to develop
breakthrough treatments and therapies
Pfizer revealed today that it has found
a promising new treatment that might
prevent the virus from replicating and
that hopes it hopes to begin testing in
clinical trials very soon it's going to
be very very soon they have great great
feelings for this particular therapy and
bill Florida they think that a lot of
good things are happening through the
FDA's coronavirus treatment acceleration
program 19 therapies and treatments are
now being tested and 26 more are in the
active planning or clinical trial so we
have 19 therapies being tested currently
and 26 more are in the active planning
for clinical trials that's a big
statement that's how lots of clinical
trials for Gili ads anti rival drug REM
disappear not an anti continue and the
company has also expanded emergency use
for new patients getting good early
results by the way the companies that
manufacture
hydroxychloroquine are massively ramping
up production as you know many people
are recommending strongly z-pak be added
the z-pak
and also zinc and the federal government
continues to build our stockpiles and
distribute millions of doses for doctors
to use MSNBC broke in when he mentioned
zinc yesterday with a doctor saying
don't listen to this pleased to inform
you we're just having a lot of good
things are happening but we'll have to
see how that all works out but we have
we've purchased and we have stockpiled
millions and millions of doses hydroxy
we're distributing it some states wanted
very badly Michigan we just sent a lot
to Michigan and other areas reporting
today that we passed two million tests
completed in the United States first
time most anywhere in the country it's a
milestone for our country it's a
milestone anywhere nobody's done
anywhere close are some tests are highly
sophisticated and highly accurate at the
same time we're making important
progress on the economic front I do need
you guys just to remember we are 43rd
and testing globally per capita will
explain new steps that we're taking to
it your American workers swiftly receive
unemployment and paid leave benefits and
that employers protect the health and
safety of all workers including
essential workers on the job working
very very closely with workers and with
employers to provide for the economic
relief the Federal Reserve announced
this morning that it will provide up to
2.3 trillion dollars in support to
businesses states and local governments
six hundred billion dollars in loans
will be available for mid-sized
businesses with up to ten thousand
employees and five hundred billion
dollars will be available for states
counties with over two million residents
and cities with a population of over 1
million my administration is also
working with Congress to replenish the
very successful incredibly successful
the way it's going paycheck protection
program which is allowing hundreds
almost no one has received money yet to
keep their workers on the payroll
meaning it'll keep those businesses open
we need both demo
rats and Republicans to come together to
get this legislation completed and it
looks like it's on its way but we need
both and it should be four that are
working for the workers and if you look
and you see we have a lot of people that
are affected by that and it's a very
positive development so we have to get a
bipartisan approval of that and
hopefully that'll happen today the
Department of Education is also
announcing the availability of more than
six billion dollars in emergency grant
funding to assist college students
impacted by the cancellation of classes
and the suspension of housing a lot of
people had a lot of things suspended
housing is one of them previously we
waive student loan payments for six
months so student loan payments have
been waived for six months and we'll
discuss it after that may go further
although this medical war has separated
our citizens for a period of time it's
also united our entire nation I think I
can say like almost never before
Americans are moving forward with common
purpose and shared resolve determined to
vanquish the virus and lift our nation
to even greater heights
we are supremely confident in the
magnificent future that awaits the
American people right and with that
before I invite our vice president and
our great Vice President and Jeanne
Scalia to speak we'll take a few
questions and then I'm going back into
negotiations on oil and on Airlines
let's just see if we're getting the
please I'm just looking for a feed where
we see the reporters use kaliya to speak
we'll take a few questions and then I'm
going back into negotiations on oil and
on Airlines yeah please
conversation with President Putin in the
Qingyuan I had a very good conversation
did you organize that fall and do they
understand the problems we're calling
yeah yeah you know there's a lot of
there's a lot of there's so much
production nobody even knows what to do
with it that's how it's working and
Saudi Arabia and as you know Russia it's
well known that we're producing a lot
and they were perhaps fighting with each
other over the production and the amount
of oil being produced and frankly
there's not enough room to even store it
our storage is now full gonna be very
soon our strategic national storage is I
said there's a great time to fill it up
load it up with oil that frankly is
they're flying at pricing that nobody's
ever seen before I don't think we've
seen this probably since the 1950s that
was with big dollars so we'll see what
happens the conversation was very good
they're getting close to a deal that's
OPEC and many other countries outside of
OPEC and we'll see what happens you know
I think that we're getting along very
well we had a very good we had a very
good call I think it was a very good
call we're gonna see what happens but it
was a very good call
they'll probably announce something
either today or tomorrow one way or the
other could be good could be not so good
but I think one way the other go ahead
the administration discussed the
possibility of reopening the country
when the administration does not have an
adequate nationwide testing system or
this virus don't you need a nationwide
test system for the virus before you
realize we have a great testing system
we have the best right now the best
testing system in the world but there
are certain sections right now there are
certain sections in the country that are
in phenomenal shape already other
sections are coming online other
sections are going down and we in
addition to that are giving out millions
of tests and every day we're doing it
exponentially we're exponentially
remember we are 43rd globally per capita
in tests of our country and do massive
testing it's not necessary but it would
be a good thing to have
wasn't to make sure people are safe
going back to work you don't want to
send people back to the workplace you
want to have it and we're going to see
if we have it you need it no is it a
nice thing to do yes we're talking about
three hundred and twenty five million
people and that's not gonna happen as
you can imagine and nope it would never
happen with anyone else either other
countries do it but they do it in a
limited form will probably be the leader
of the pack please what do you say to
the 16 million Americans more than 16
million Americans who have lost their
jobs in the last three weeks and fear
that the economy won't just bounce back
like you said well I think the economy
is going to do very well now that's just
my feeling it's a strong feeling I've
had good proper feelings about a lot of
things over the years and I think we're
gonna do well we're doing very we're at
the lower end of the curb in terms of
death which is a terrible word a
terrible dark word that we've
experienced like nobody has ever seen
before in this country I mean we're
we're have numbers that are terrible but
when you look at the lower levels of a
hundred lower prediction levels of a
hundred hundred and twenty thousand to
two hundred and twenty thousand or if we
did nothing up to 2.2 million people
we're looking at a much lower level than
the level of I hope than the level of a
hundred thousand so we're gonna see
we're going to have to you can never you
can never do anything about the people
that lost their loved ones and loved
their lost their friends and I mean the
great friendships and I'm not sure a lot
of people will ever be the same but I
think our country from an economic
standpoint will end up being stronger
than ever we have tremendous stimulus we
have tremendous stimulus plans we have
things in the works that are going to
really I think far the country I think
that what's going to happen is we're
going to have a big bounce rather than a
small bounce some slang which is like
it's over you know like we've won and I
think honestly I think our country is
going to be back from an economic
standpoint again you can never replace
the people that were lost and to their
families certainly you can never do a
thing like that but
we will have succeeded in many ways
hopefully keeping the number way below
our minimum numbers and also from an
economic standpoint you know we met with
the mental health people today and that
takes a trim this is taking a tremendous
toll mentally on a lot of people and I
think we're going to open up strong I
think we're going to open up very
successfully and I'd like to say even
more successfully than before please
about 23 dollars a barrel of New York
what would you want to see the price do
you want it at 30 40 $50 a beer well I I
want to see it where there's a certain
market but I also don't want I don't
want to see it where people are have no
idea you know we're opening up we'll be
opening up areas for storage of oil
massive areas for storage of oil because
oil today is not selling and what
happened is the virus knocked out 40% of
the market immediate you know that you
know the number 40% now there was a lot
of oil but it was very controllable all
of a sudden they lost 40 percent you
look at the road you look at the car you
look at what's going on there's nobody
driving there's no reason for it right
now that'll start coming back but we are
storing millions of barrels of oil that
nobody thought would even be possible
frankly ships turned out to be a good
business for some people because they're
filling up tankers sending them out to
sea and not saying where to go they're
just sitting out there loaded up with
like this guy so we want to save our
energy in this country we want to make
sure that our energy companies
businesses and employees workers remain
strong so that's how I'm involved and I
think that's gonna happen so right now
if you look you're probably talking 23
25 there's any way that we can get it up
we need a minimum number so the
companies don't but the name in that
Bloomberg reporter he's always asking
these goading questions the Trump and I
love it and you know we're now energy
independent we could do something well
we only used our oil but I think the
long-term benefit is to be able to just
go with the market and it's gonna work
out it's all going to work out if you
looked at three weeks
ago as you know as we talked about it
three weeks ago and two weeks ago this
was catastrophic I think it's really
hitting bottom and I think that I mean
we've had a bottom but now at twenty
three dollars and twenty five dollars
and probably heading up at the same time
we save our energy and we also produce
great cheap energy and we save our jobs
yeah their banks don't know how to
access this money that's right they're
trying to apply they can't figure it out
so where does the fault line is a lot of
the banks I don't think there's a fault
with their doing record numbers of
dollars they're dealing with many
community banks they're dealing with
banks almost no one's gotten the money
yet it's really important to understand
almost no one's gotten the money yet and
they're dealing with the bankers can't
go that quickly but I'm hearing it's a
very very successful rollout they didn't
want changes in applications they want
changes in in loan requirements etc but
they are taking billions and billions of
dollars worth of loans and in the very
near future the banks will be relieving
the money they'll be paying out the
money yep please still expecting the
u.s. nca to take effect on July 1st and
considering the auto industry is hurting
these days are you ready to postpone the
what we have a deal yeah the deal is
with Canada would deal with Mexico we
have a deal and obviously the deal is
different from the standpoint that
production will be lower from the state
we have a deal it's a signed deal it's a
deal that say one of the worst deals
that we've ever had was NAFTA one of the
worst trade deals ever made by any
country anywhere will be terminating
that and the new deal is a great deal
for our country so that's something now
again we get hit by the virus and we'll
see where that all goes but certainly
car production is going to be down for a
little while but ultimately good for our
farmers great for our farmers we'll be
helping our farmers by the way we have
money going out to our farmers in the
pretty near future having to do with you
see what's happened the farmers got hurt
very bad
by all of this people are eating less
from the standpoint that there's no
restaurants are open no businesses are
open no hotels are happen they'll start
to come back but we're gonna be helping
out our farmers yep Philip Whiteman real
Flair politics earlier you mentioned
project skybridge and we're hearing that
through that project a lot of the PPE
that was sent out to other countries is
coming back to this country do you I
dunno when we'll be able to bring a
majority of that back and then I'm
frustrated that US aid allowed a lot of
that aid to go out the door in the first
place
chef right I'm not because we're we're
in very good shape you'll be speaking
with Mike Pence about this and a little
well yeah you look at the hospitals you
look at what's going on I spoke to
yesterday I spoke with the governor of
Louisiana I'm saying do you think we
need that extra thousand beds that were
in the process of building and we are
really in good shape you're not hearing
people in needing ventilators much in
fact we're going to start helping other
countries with ventilators we're going
to end up having a lot of ventilators
for future should something happen for
hospitals ideally to keep and have but
no I think we're in very very good shape
we have calls with governor's all the
time and the governor is in very good
shape now we have helped we have sent
billions and billions and billions of
dollars between ventilators equipment
protective equipment masks we have 500
million masks coming 500 million from
one group five hundred it'll be three
hundred million and two hundred million
over a short period of time no I think
we're in very good shape please speaking
of testing some experts including Scott
got we have talked about seven
50,000 tests per week being needed
before the economy is opened can you
address that do you agree with those
numbers if not how many tests per week
do you think we should have before that
cause using the word needed because I
don't think it's needed but I think
we're going to try and hit a number like
that that's a very high number but we're
gonna be trying to hit it and we
probably might be able to do that please
go ahead sir Thank You mr. president
today the Democrats pushed for more
rescue money for States and hospitals
which are complaining that they needed
to fight the corona virus pandemic do
you think hospitals and states need this
money when you so I do and I do support
something but I support it for the next
phase it's much simpler in the next
phase whether that phase is
infrastructure or whatever so I'm gonna
leave you now with Mike Pence and with
Eugene Scalia and if you would I look
forward to seeing you tomorrow we'll see
you tomorrow we have a lot of I think a
lot of very big news to report we've had
a tremendous day between I believe
what's happening with the energy
industry and I believe what's happening
with Airlines I look forward to seeing
you thank you very much everybody thank
you
Wow I'm just wandering off I love how
bright afternoon everyone about you just
sits when Trump leaves the present
moment we have now cleared more than two
million tests across the country and and
I'm pleased to report we're testing more
than a hundred thousand people a day now
but we're we're working around the clock
to scale up the new types of tests that
the FDA has approved in record time and
every American can be confident that
we'll continue to build out that
structure going forward for the weeks
ahead and the months ahead at the
present moment there's more than 450,000
Americans who have tested positive for
the corona virus and sadly more than
16,000 Americans have lost their lives
and as president Trump just said our
hearts go out to the families that have
lost loved ones and I want to assure you
that all of us working at every level
understand these are not numbers these
are lives and our heartfelt condolences
during this heartbreaking week pence
seems a little like slowed down to that
and family that's lost a loved one to
the coronavirus it has been a difficult
week but as dr. Burks will reflect in
just a few moments as we look at the
data literally on a county-by-county
basis every day we continue to see
evidence that that in areas where the
epidemic has impacted most the Greater
New York City area
Louisiana the Detroit Metro the Denver
Metro we continue to see evidence of
stabilization and and it appears as dr.
Byrd suggests that we are we are close
to the peak in each of those areas so
impacted we also express gratitude and
appreciation for the people of
California in Washington State who
continue to be low and steady in the
number of cases that are mer
there we're watching the Chicago metro
area we're watching the Boston metro
area and as dr. Burks will discuss we we
just continue to urge every American to
put into practice the president's
coronavirus guidelines presidents
because all evidence indicates from the
west coast to what we're beginning to
see in major outbreak areas on the East
Coast it's working America and it's
working because you're doing it and we
encourage you onward in that today the
White House coronavirus that task force
met but most of the team also met with
Republicans and Democrats in two
separate conference calls of the United
States Senate Secretary minuchin our
health experts Admiral Paul of check dr.
Hahn and joined us as we discussed a
broad range of issues the Treasury
Secretary touched on the Paycheck
protection program now in a day five
reporting 125 billion dollars has been
approved so far Kru 30,000 new
individual users and thirty-nine hundred
lenders are participating we also
discussed that the Treasury Department
will issue a new frequently asked
question document tonight an FAQ as
they're known to clarify how seasonal
businesses can participate in the
paycheck protection program as well with
regard to direct payments to Americans
the Treasury secretary assured senators
and we assure every American that we
remain on the timetable where the first
payments in direct deposits will go out
by the end of next week for the average
family of four that'll be three thousand
four hundred dollars in direct financial
support and will no doubt be welcome
news anyone who is interested in
additional information on any of these
programs can go to Treasury gov or
sba.gov since we last spoke
I spoke with the governor Laura Kelly of
Kansas governor Andy Beshear of Kentucky
also spoke to governors of Texas
and Rhode Island I assured each one of
them as we continue to work through the
process of making sure that we
distribute the resources at the point of
the need is it at president Trump's
direction
our objective working through FEMA is to
make sure that states have what they
need when they need it and to see the
progress that we've made the president
just reflected on in New York and New
Jersey Louisiana and the partnership we
forged with governor's in those states
California and Washington state before
we trust gives confidence to governor's
and leaders of states across the country
most importantly our dedicated health
care workers that we will be there to
meet that need should that a need arise
the present moment
FEMA reports the president has approved
fifty-four major disaster declarations
and states around the country have stood
up 29,000 a National Guard 11,000 of
which are fully funded by the federal
government under title 32 also speaking
of our military at the present moment we
receive a report today from the
Department of Defense that 4,100
active-duty military medical personnel
have been deployed in New York New
Jersey and Connecticut and they are
personnel that are working on the ground
at the Javits Center working of course
at the USNS comfort ship but because at
the present moment the utilization of of
both of those temporary facilities has
been fairly modest the DoD actually
worked with the city of New York to
establish what amounts to a uniform temp
service they called it the bullpen and
today they literally deployed from the
ship and from the Javits Center
seventy-five medical personnel to
relieve dedicated health care workers
within the hospital system in the city
of New York and we'll continue to do
that we're going to make sure those a
federal temporary hospital and Javits
Center is fully staffed we'll make sure
the USNS comfort is staffed but
but the physician I'd love to get to the
doctors I don't know about you guys are
gonna be also be deployed across the
city to bring much-needed relief to our
health care workers in our system from
the VA standpoint we've opened up VA
facilities in New York City East Orange
New Jersey Detroit Michigan and we are
opening up the VA facility to
coronavirus patients in Shreveport
Louisiana
finally I mentioned that today we
exceeded more than two million tests
that have been performed across the
country and also literally working with
the US Public Health Service states
around the country have stood up
hundreds of drive-through testing sites
and just this week FEMA and the US
Public Health Service announced that we
will give an option to States to
transition from a federal testing site a
dozens of which have been assembled
around the country to a state managed
site yeah what I am from what we know
they're actually starting to pull
funding for the federal testing sites
it's not quite as gingersnaps and
waterfalls as he's talking about areas
that they think are most important but
but we're also processing requests for
continued federal participation in
states from New Jersey to Louisiana to
Illinois Colorado and Texas and we want
to assure people in communities all
across the country that we'll continue
to partner with States to the extent
that they prefer us to be a part of it
with regard to the air bridge
three flights were scheduled to arrive
today in Chicago New York and
dallas-fort worth forty nine flights are
scheduled over the next three days and
we continue to work supplies we continue
to literally leave no stone unturned
around America and around the world
we're literally in the process of
acquiring tens of millions of supplies
that are being brought into a
distribution system organized out of
FEMA and focused on the area's most in
need we're also bringing real innovation
and at the at the White House
coronavirus task force today we we
tasked the FDA and CMS to review the
feasibility of allowing hospital workers
to use cloth gowns
for performing procedures it was
observed that 20 years ago most
physicians and most surgeons wore cloth
gowns every day and laundered them but
it's transitioned to disposable gowns
and we're working at very rapidly in the
next 24 hours and we'll have guidance
for hospitals and health care workers
about the ability to do in effect
recycle gowns and make sure that we have
the supplies that we need as the
president mentioned today the president
and the first lady and I and my wife
Karen we're honored to be a part of a
conference call with mental health
professionals from all around the
country and we know while there are
families that are struggling with the
coronavirus and struggling with
heartbreaking loss to the coronavirus we
understand this is a very challenging
time for every American but most
especially Americans history yeah that's
a good point people are making remember
when two weeks ago it was all about this
machine to sanitize masks nobody said a
word about it and now they're just
talking about sending millions of masks
do we know what came of that is anybody
actually doing it and we've also issued
guidance for using technology to remain
connected to social support groups and
we just urge everyone everyone who may
be feeling a an emotional burden or a
vulnerability during this time to to
reach out to the many resources that are
there and to know that you're not alone
and that we're with you and we'll get
through this and we'll get through this
together
so despite heartbreaking losses that
continue this week in communities from
New York to New Jersey to Louisiana
there are sounds of progress and hope of
bounce the reality is that we see new
projections from the experts and if the
projections are right it's because it's
working America it's because the
American people are putting into
practice the social distancing caring
for their neighbors and their loved ones
and their family members and putting
their health first and we just want to
urge every American and continue to put
those principles and guidelines into
practice every day with that I'm gonna
invite dr. deborah birx up for an update
and doctor pouchy we'll hear from the
Secretary of Labor and take a few
questions Thank You mr. vice president
um so I wanted to cover today not only
what we're seeing across the United
States but some of the testing data to
assure from the prior question if we're
testing you I'm sure you're following
our numbers every day and the amount
we're going up about a hundred and
eighteen thousand to one hundred and
twenty thousand per day are being tested
so we're way over the 750,000 per week
currently remember three weeks ago they
were talking about millions a week they
just like they completely change what
the bar is and then they're like we
killed I have about 75% of that test
data in now about 1.5 million of those
tests have them reported in I just
wanted to give you some ideas because
sometimes we think that we're only
testing in the hospitals that this
should give you an idea of the quantity
and the types of tests that have
occurred so we've tested over 200,000
young people up to age 25 they have
about 11% positivity rate over half a
million people between 25 and 45 they
have a 17% positive rate now remember in
order to get tested you have to have
symptoms so this gives you an idea of
the number of people who have symptoms
that are not infected with corona virus
another nearly half a million people
between 45 and 65 their positivity rate
is 21% another nearly 200,000 between 65
and 85 22% positive and a small group of
about 30 plus thousand individuals over
85 and they have a 24 percent positivity
rates and so this gives you an idea of
we're testing throughout all age
categories I see a lot of men in the
today I just want to remind them about
the importance of health care of the
male-female ratio 56% of the people who
are tested are female 16 percent
positive 44 percent male 23 percent
positive so again it gives you an idea
about how men often don't present in the
health care delivery system until they
have greater symptomatology this is to
all of our men out there no matter what
age group if you have symptoms you
should be tested and make sure that you
are tested
we appreciate you engaging in that and
also really recognizing the issues about
comorbidities and making sure that we're
addressing those I had a series of great
calls with them about 17 states that are
in our more rural areas specifically
around our indigenous people and tribal
nations is a very reassuring call and
you know we are testing across the
country we do have about 63% of states
that have less than 10% positive despite
significant testing and within the
indigenous peoples and tribal nations
they're seeing the same thing that we're
seeing across the nation increase issues
are wrong those with comorbidities and
those of elderly but also issues in
nursing homes and so we're really they
are testing many of these states are
still capable of doing full contact
tracing and so they've been doing
contact tracing from nursing home
outbreaks and other outbreaks it really
gives us a clear impression of no matter
what we do in the future we need to
really ensure that nursing homes have
Sentinel surveillance so what do I mean
by that that we're actively testing in
nursing homes both the residents and the
workers at all times that is where and
that's how we saw this at the beginning
that's what we saw in Washington State
and that's what we're seeing in many of
the states that have very low case
attack rates the other thing that I want
to leave you with I mean we certainly
know how desperate and difficult the
situation has been in
New York over the last few weeks and
we've been telling and and talking about
how this would be the week that would be
most difficult because of the large
proportion of cases that are coming from
the New York metro area what's been
encouraging to us those early states
outside of Washington in California
which still have extraordinarily low
attack rates because of their level of
mitigation all of the new areas that are
having new increase in cases we talked
about them yesterday Washington and
Baltimore and the Philadelphia metro
area that includes Camden Wilmington and
the counties around Philadelphia we're
seeing that the case number is what
we'll get to as far as attack rates we
talked about one in seven in a thousand
in New York that are being measured
these are coming in even with their
progress of their curve in the one to
two per thousand range showing that when
you start mitigation early it has a very
different impact all of this data is
coming together the testing rates the
SERO positivity the age groups who
really needs hospitalization ICU the
innovative pieces coming from we heard a
great report from Louisiana this morning
on the phone call where they talked
about a minimum now a 40% of people
coming off of ventilators alive and
leaving the hospital this is very
encouraging to us really shows amazing
progress clinically at each of these
hospitals and the real lessons what
we're learning and sharing across
hospitals but really shows us that the
original outbreaks were very large but
the newer ones that we talked about in
Washington and while the Philadelphia
and Baltimore it looks like their attack
rates and the TAC rates in Denver and
some of these other states that we have
been talking about are much lower than
New York and New Jersey and this gives
us hope about really understanding how
to integrate this information together
not dealing with a model but the
real-life cases that are occurring and
understanding
how to move forward together to really
have a different future so thank you
very much
thank you very much mr. vice president
so just reflecting about what we've been
doing over the last few days remember
last weekend when we made the forecast
that this would really be a bad week as
I mentioned yesterday and the day before
it is in the sense of deaths a bad week
in fact every day this seems to be a
record of number of deaths compared to
the day before in fact New York today
had again another record of I think the
city itself was about eight hundred and
twenty plus deaths but what we were
predicting with the increase and the
real adherence to the physical
separation the guidelines that the vice
president talks about the physical
separation at the same time as we're
seeing the increase in deaths we're
seeing rather dramatic decrease in the
need for hospitalizations like I think
yesterday was something like 200 new
hospitalizations and it's been as high
as 1400 at any given time so that is
going in the right direction I say that
and I always remind myself when I say
that that means that what we are doing
is working and therefore we need to
continue keep LLL do it I know I sound
like a broken record that's good I want
to sound like a broken record let's just
keep doing it I get questions a lot dr.
Burks and I about these numbers the
projections that you went with from
100,000 200,000 now down to 60,000
that's a sign that when as I keep saying
when you take the data you have and you
reinsert it into the model the model
modifies data is real model is
hypothesis okay so that's what you have
to do and that's what I think we're
seeing the other thing that some just
broad general good news from the
standpoint of a scientific standpoint
that there are a lot of candidate
potential therapeutics that are going
into clinical trials now that we're
sponsoring at the NIH the kinds of
clinical trials that will give us the
answer
safe are they effective and just what is
the capability of using them under what
circumstances as prophylaxis as
treatment in early disease in late
disease so as the time goes by and we
have the public health measures to try
and contain this we're doing an awful
lot from a scientific standpoint so that
when we do get to next year next fall
next winter hopefully we'll have
something that we can offer in addition
to the very important public health
measures good needs that they happy to
answer questions later so I'm gonna mute
this guy just cuz I don't think this is
the most interesting guy I want to play
for you guys a voicemail that I received
today
disguised to look like a call from where
I used to live it's related to the virus
it's meant to sound like a neighbor
checking up from on me listen to who it
is that is calling around take a listen
my neighbor's sheltering in place and
these are hard times for people I was
just thinking in and I'm hoping that you
your householder will I was hearing
something that's helped me it's a
non-profit Bible Bible study program and
I hope you for yourself so again JW
Jehovah's Witnesses yeah so the
Jehovah's Witnesses that normally are
hanging out by the subway and stuff with
literature are just casually suggesting
what I need now what I need in my life
on this holiest of Passover Seder days
imagine is to go to the Jehovah's
Witnesses website ladies and gentlemen
needless to say I will not be calling I
will not be calling alright that's it
for me today we will be back tomorrow
show stream all of that stuff thanks to
everybody who joined me
you